this episode of legal eagle was made
possible by skill share learn to think
like a lawyer for free for two months by
clicking the link in the description
last week Kim Kardashian announced her
intention to take the California Bar
Exam without going to law school like
all things Kardashian's made huge
headlines is this simply a new plot for
the reality show or is Kim Kardashian
expanding her home video and makeup
empire to include a law practice
discovered the truth in this week's real
law review Kim Kardashian made news last
week by announcing her intention to take
the California Bar Exam without
graduating from Law School
this process is called reading the law
and it actually used to be the dominant
way that Americans became lawyers like
most lawyers Kim made her announcement
with a splashy article and a photo
spread in vogue the vogue article
describes Kim's house as having a master
bedroom the size of quote and airplane
hangar a pile of books on tort law a
bathroom big enough for a basketball
team and of course Kanye West I am the
number one most impactful artist of our
generation I am Shakespeare in the flesh
what Disney hashtag relatable but on a
more serious note Kim explains that she
decided to become a lawyer after helping
secure the release of Alice Marie
Johnson a prisoner who spent a decade in
prison for being a nonviolent drug
offender although Kim was mostly in
intermediary bringing up the case with
Kanye's friend Donald Trump the
experience made her feel out of her
depth she stated quote that I want to be
able to fight for people who have paid
their dues to society I just felt like
the system could be so different and I
wanted to fight to fix it and if I knew
more than I could do more admirably Kim
has continued to be involved in prison
reform efforts so apparently she started
the process of becoming a lawyer last
summer with an apprenticeship with a
California law firm her goal apparently
is to take the California bar in 2020 of
course Kim is also the daughter of a
famous lawyer Robert Kardashian who was
probably best known as being OJ
Simpson's friend and attorney during the
1995 murder trial mr. Kardashian passed
away in 2003 of esophageal cancer now
like all things
- in Kim's announcement was of course
met with a cycle of praise and backlash
her personal lawyer Marti Singh who I've
actually worked with on a few occasions
at the firm of Lavely and singer said
that quote I believe that she will be a
terrific lawyer and will be an asset to
any firm that hires her including our
own that's probably true you can imagine
that hiring a billionaire reality TV
star would probably be a boon to any law
firm that she decided to work with
now of course detractors rolled their
eyes at Kim's depiction of her studies
especially the comment where she said
quote took my first test got a 100 super
easy for me the reading is what really
gets me it's so time consuming the
concepts I grasp in two seconds but I
think for the time being at least she
deserves the benefit of the doubt it is
difficult to do the process of reading
for the law and passing the California
Bar Exam the California Bar Exam which
is notoriously the hardest Bar Exam in
the entire country but let's talk a
little bit about this process law school
is usually three years long and involves
grueling years of studying writing
taking exams and learning to think and
argue like a lawyer and of course after
attaining your law degree the recent law
graduate has to take a State Bar Exam
once that person passes the exam they
are good to go at least in terms of
being able to practice in that one
particular state every state has its own
bar exam so passing one test doesn't
really give you the right to practice in
another state and if you pass the bar in
California no other state lets you just
wave in because California doesn't let
any other lawyers wave into the state of
California but it hasn't always been
that way
in colonial America people were
suspicious of lawyers even though the 28
of the signers of the Declaration of
Independence actually had legal training
that's because back in England the
profession was only open to elites and
of course Americans were revolting
against a society with a very strong
class system eventually Americans
realized that they needed lawyers and
they decided to make the training
markedly different than what their
forefathers had practiced the first
American trained lawyers on US soil had
to complete a seven-year clerkship with
a lawyer or a judge New York not
surprisingly led the way here insisting
on the completion of a four-year degree
followed by a fine
year clerkship this model for legal
training wasn't all that different from
apprentice in masonry mill right or
plumbing the training was overseen by a
mentor lawyer who would make sure that
the potential law graduate absorbed all
the knowledge necessary for the
profession of course there were some
problems with this model as it applied
to lawyers apprenticeship training was
all practical so students did not
receive much theoretical knowledge today
someone argue that you get way too much
theoretical knowledge at law school and
not enough practical knowledge the
practice of law of course requires both
it requires intellectual rigor moral
skills writing skills research skills
this can be hard to pick up in a
fast-paced legal environment and in fact
many apprentices found themselves
overworked and stuck doing menial tasks
rather than actually studying the law
itself over the years a formal system of
legal education started to develop with
law schools opening and eventually every
state starting its own bar however in
most states people could still become
lawyers without actually attending law
school some of America's most famous
lawyers did exactly that for example Abe
Lincoln grew up on the frontier and
couldn't afford law school he did just
fine
in fact Lincoln didn't even apprentice
with anyone he just read some books and
passed the test and started a law firm
and ended up as one of the most revered
American presidents of all time
the process of reading the law which Kim
Kardashian Polamalu the process of
reading the law which Kim Kardashian is
actually going through also works for
Clarence Darrow John Adams Thomas
Jefferson Daniel Webster and chief judge
of the Supreme Court John Marshall in
the late 19th century fewer than 20% of
lawyers actually went to law school
which is where the American Bar
Association enters the picture in 1878 a
group of lawyers started the American
Bar Association to promote for greater
uniformity in the legal profession the
ABA wanted to restrict entrance into the
profession and spent years lobbying
States to restrict the practice of law
to only people who actually went to law
school and they were pretty successful
although most states now require a
person to graduate from law school to be
eligible to take the bar exam a few
outlier states still allow non graduates
to take the test today only California
Virginia Washington and from
will allow you to take the bar exam
without actually going to law school
meanwhile New York Wyoming and New
Jersey lets students take the bar exam
if they complete some sort of mini
version of law school for people living
in those states taking the bar exam
through a combination of apprenticeship
and schooling could make sense as I
covered in another video the cost debt
and time involved can make law school a
difficult proposition for many people
but let's go back to Kim Kardashian what
does she have to do to be able to take
and pass the California Bar Exam well
she's going to need to spend 18 hours a
week for four years with a lawyer or a
judge to get the go-ahead to sit for the
California Bar Exam she's also going to
need to take what we usually refer to as
the baby bar exam later this summer the
baby bar is a threshold test for people
who want to go to an unaccredited law
school or intend to read the law without
actually going to law school it's a
gatekeeper to make sure that you're not
going to sit for the mainbar exam if you
can't at least pass a smaller version of
it ahead of time Kim's supervising
lawyer must devote at least five hours a
week to direct supervision and must
administer tests to demonstrate that she
is actually learning something Kant
would you stop taking pictures of
yourself your sister's going to jail Kim
has already been reading law books
working at a law office and taking tests
so I would say this is not exactly a
publicity stunt at least for the time
being she will have to work in three
more years of weekly legal work and
study to get her shot at the California
Bar Exam in 2020 if she passes she will
join a very rare Club in 2014
eighty-four thousand people took a bar
exam but just 60 were apprentices and of
those 60 people only 17 actually passed
the bar exam now if you want to read for
the law like Kim Kardashian you'll need
a Productivity system to manage your
time and learn to study efficiently I
highly recommend my friend Thomas
Frank's Skillshare Productivity master
class how to create a custom system that
works even if you're not trying to pivot
from being a Kardashian to a lawyer
it'll help you transform your personal
and professional life by creating a
simple customized productivity system oh
it's on or if you already are a lawyer
and want to pivot to being a Kardashian
style reality star you can learn all the
beauty tips that Thomas Frank uses in
Chelsea Baker's Skillshare class on
applying makeup using professional
techniques Skillshare is an online
learning community that has over 20,000
classes on everything like lifestyle
design and technology
the first 500 legal eagles will get two
free months of Skillshare when you click
on the link below the free premium
membership gives you unlimited access to
must know topics so you can improve your
skills and learn new things so click on
the link get two free months and start
learning to think like a lawyer today it
could even help you become a reality
star lawyer oh my gosh Alice you're out
do you think Kim will stick with it do
you think that people should be able to
practice the law without going to law
school
leave your objections in the comments
and check out my other real law reviews
over here where I will see you in court